Partha testing test Noah today we're
testing the new continuous variable
transmission and the Subaru Forester our
test driver Sacha Kopp has come out here
to this test track to put the CVT
through its paces previous versions of
the CVT have proved less than optimal
that's mostly due to what's called the
rubber band effect where the engine revs
up without the car accelerating fast but
the engineers at the schaeffler group
have come up with a new design that's
aimed and solving that problem
the c40 Tasha says the CVT does exactly
what it's supposed to do and that's to
provide an uninterrupted supply of power
to the drive wheels but when you take a
fast curve you'll notice that the seats
in the Forester need more lateral
support the Forester is a midsize
crossover SUV that weighs in at one
point six tons and is powered by a 177
kilowatt gasoline engine it can hit 100
kilometers and just 7.5 seconds older
versions of the continuous variable
transmission couldn't handle high torque
loads but the engineers at Schaeffler
have come up with a more reliable design
that features a metal belt and a pulley
system their new CVT can generate a peak
torque of up to 500 Newton meters
torque is especially important when
you're driving around in rough terrain
we decided to see whether the Subaru
Forester really lives up to the name
sport utility vehicle the mule X mode
component provides good for wheel
traction at speeds of up to 40 km/h and
it provides stability when you're
driving up or down hills Madame Foster
Subaru executive your cracka says they
designed the Forester to appeal to
people who enjoy driving in open country
and who drive in cities some customers
will want to attach a trailer to the
vehicle for horses or camping equipment
the Forester has a towing capacity of
two tons that should be perfect for them
the Forester also offers a ground
clearance of 220 millimetres low fuel
consumption seating comfort and
excellent handling on the road families
and people who enjoy the outdoors will
appreciate these features especially the
extra ground clearance dingey go Declan
airborne fire permitted inspection
subaru has also made some changes to the
foresters exterior design mostly the
front end the new additions include a
taller grille and a sporty looking
bumper not much changed to the sides of
the vehicle
and the lettering on the rear end will
make it clear to anyone what sort of
Subaru they're following
Sasha says Subaru considers itself a
nishan Porter here in Germany with sales
just under ten thousand vehicles that
works out at a market share of 0.3
percent obviously Subaru is at this
point not a major player in the German
car market but at least the CVT
transmission is proven itself efficient
and reliable we were impressed with the
way it provides a smooth drive for both
driver and passengers